her parents are just believe that one
now we're not delete now miss the best
part of the video the alcohols get image
Nina everybody ha okay
good morning hello from Los Angeles yeah
so we are on our well it's an
anniversary trip kind of yeah tomorrow
what we celebrated different we
celebrate from when we started dating
not from when we got married but it's
our it's our marriage anniversary
tomorrow hey happy University grass so
we are in LA and we thought you should
we block this should we not like this
and they decide today we're gonna block
it so we didn't film us getting here but
we had an awesome seats with extra
legroom so we're going to film some of
our day we are here at our Airbnb place
so these guys are cool they wrote happy
Anniversary welcome on their chalkboard
and it's a it's a small place but fun
you can see the mass Tina made on the
bed all the cab crazy sleeper we're
gonna get some food and go ok here we
are driving to LA
okay we've arrived at our first stop
there's the images walking westfield
century city which is a shopping plaza
we're looking for food because we're
hungry i'm a little let down honestly
because we see McDonald's McDonald's
McDonald's and Burger King and KFC like
we want something healthy come on
California give me some smoothies one
cool thing about the parking lot this is
cool they have these lights where red
means that there's a spot that's been
taken the green lights mean that it's
available and there's blue ones them now
don't know what that means Oh
handicapped that's cool all right Nina
wants a smoothie too let's go Nina's
favorite star right behind you know
behind you sephora it's lunch time for
Nina what did you get
look at the presentation I'm liking that
you
so we're here at the Grove which is
another popular shopping area here in LA
West Hollywood what's the general plan
what do we actually do could we look for
different insightful usually find
shopping area not being makeup makeup
makeup sure fun neighborhoods we don't
really do the museum's or the art
galleries or the like major history
stuff it's more like vibrant communities
vibrant areas and a little soft
adventure we gotta find something like
soft adventure to do anything up I don't
know something a little a little scary
is not something different right so
that's how we plan our vacations so here
we are okay so we're in Hollywood and
Nina wanted to go to this makeup store
really badly and I walked in and got
instantly bored and thought hey this is
a good chance to make some videos for
you guys and I went on a really long
walk because I was going on a rant for
one of your questions and Nina just came
out of the store now I'm hustling back
to go see her cuz she's waiting for me
it's very hot she's frustrated but we're
gonna see what she bought
Russia's cleaner so I always wanted this
like brushes what I'm excited by Xena
said I always wanted this and she got it
yes or about making dreams happen yeah
so it's very hot Nina sweating so we're
going to go so we're at johnny rockets
and our dinner just arrived we both got
burgers we got minion fries we're in
line at the theater because we're gonna
go watch a Hollywood movie in Hollywood
does that make sense testicle Nina fell
asleep for the whole movie sometimes
though you have a good nap and now it's
nighttime it's a little cooler and we're
going to go get another booster juice
and then enjoy the rest of our night
today's our actual anniversary Nina had
a very nice special message this morning
you did nah she cried and she had to do
her makeup again what do you mean you
did what they need to know it's special
today we're off to the beach Venice
Beach set some fun
soft adventure alright aside for some
lunch on the same
i'm meltus water must eat right now so
we're chillin in Santa Monica now and we
walked by this pizza place and the smell
was awesome so check it out and we went
in and we saw this and my mouth started
to drool and as you hit the usual rule
if your mouth drools probably order
eleven past 11
we slept in a little bit and chilled at
our place so we all got a late start we
have to be back in Santa Monica for
honest company to do my interview at
three o'clock and so that was not proper
planning Evan not great planning consent
modify yesterday we're going to hang out
in LA for a couple hours and then head
over to Santa Monica and hopefully
discover some fun stuff in LA so here we
go first up Grand Central Market okay we
made it to the honest company we are
here to meet with mr. Tesla man
Christopher gavigan but first there were
some food trucks outside and Nina wants
to get something so I'm going to check
it it okay so we just finished with
honest company dude talks crazy fast and
awesome like we've got so much done in a
short amount of time we have to do one
more hang out afterwards and Nina walks
out with bag full of product full of
product everything from dish soap to
hang creams to deodorants to sunscreen
this the floor cleaner everything
everything so Nina Nina is all excited
What did he say we walked in oh do you
have any you guys want any products and
he's like oh maybe sure and then she
goes crazy in the locker room like oh I
also have try hands and I need soap and
oh I also okay we have also now made a
decision to go to San Francisco because
YouTube wants to see me I got a channel
manager usually for a youtube account
you need like million plus subscribers
get a channel manager but I got a
channel manager being under 100,000 and
he called my channel one of the most
innovative you guys are seen on youtube
so thank you guys for that and now we've
got a rush
to San Francisco for a couple days and
then rush back to catch your flight home
we got some work to do we got some
products to help us get through it who
they also have a shaving oil that I'm
excited to charge shipping oil phim at
the orchard I've never use it I've never
used memories your turn I don't use the
orphan toughest nut back haven't just
had a this hiccup Gnostic oh wow your
ear hiccup yeah happy while I talk I'm
hiccupping while I'm thinkin oh ok we
just got back at seven-thirty we had
dinner and there at bread I'm exhausted
from fighting all the LA traffic and
even insisted that we stopped off at
Target to buy you just hit your head
with the magic baller my god that's
amazing about that life yeah much do we
spend on the smoothies this is only four
dollars and then when we go a travel the
next time use it
Thank ahead friends that's what you
always tell people do I say that do I
say think ahead I don't know have you
ever had a video where he said think
ahead hey Bing Bing Bing Bing yeah Thank
fake friend okay relax when you're ready
for San Francisco tomorrow
so it's early I had two and a half hours
sleep and we're off to San Francisco and
I've been tasked with putting all of
Nina's new smoothies in the car and I
need to show you guys look at all the
smoothies Anita made this one is full of
Nina smoothie this is all Nina smoothies
that she made with the magic bullet love
you baby it's early there's nobody on
the road we're not used to this in Los
Angeles let me think maybe Oh name is
yawning it up San Francisco Italy come
home I slept for the past two hours is
great hey good letter again I was
passing out I was passing out Nina was
secretive I took the first ship and
going to pass out like I need to stop I
have a pullover even we just nap on the
side of the road because i was gonna get
dangerous and then Nina took over and i
slept and i just woke up and we're
getting some wendys it's the knee
against me
also helping you visa nothing good and
we're two hours out from San Francisco
fun times ahead okay oh I think that I
found myself a cheerleader she is always
right there when I need her oh I think
that I found myself a cheerleader she is
always right there
so we made our first San Francisco
purchase the minions bad guy hot for
Hayden C Lena founder and span
ok so it's lunch time Nina's boss told
her that San Francisco had great
vietnamese food so we're here trying she
had some pho like a bunch of beef beef o
house specialty and I've got lemongrass
chicken and ride I don't remember stir
fry anyway we're here for Nina to try
two thumbs up thumbs up all right good
we're going to eat we are climbing the
insane steep hills of San Francisco to
get to the world's most crooked street
which is all the way up there how do i
pick engage the slope here but it's
pretty bad
Alcatraz
so Nina wanted to sit down and relax and
grab a drink so she ordered this
ginormous 60 ounces this sangria Nina
doesn't have a high alcohol tolerance so
this might be a fun 1230 the cow all
right here we go let's get drinking so
we are less than halfway through and I'm
already feeling a little bit tipsy
Nina's not doing her fair share of
drinking you slowly enjoying I'm what am
I am I chugging a bag I'm checking it
back and like whoa eat some food
you want to see me drunk
will I get drunk tonight let's see what
happens I'm treating this like it's a
Frappuccino you know when you're holding
the drink and you just like you want to
drink it right back for Tino sounds is
down lean it and it's not this drink is
not meant to be down in this fashion
so you guys down drinks like that and
when you want vacation do you reflect on
your business in your life comment below
I want to know i'm a little tipsy so I
need food right now so it's a famous
pier 39 here in San Francisco tons of
food options and we always make our
decision based on what makes our mouth
water so the two things that get it for
us was a bread place boudin where we're
going to get something and then a waffle
phone as I said the waffle cone I'm not
good watering so I guess yeah so we have
to get a waffle cone although it's
freezing but time I might jewel on
myself so we're gonna get we're gonna go
to boo day get some bread something and
then waffle cone good so these are
famous for their sourdough Nina got the
clam chowder sourdough bowl that's
steaming hot and I got the sourdough
pepperoni pizza looks good actually what
happened to this don't look at the side
it like a little dwarf kisser
yeah I mean
okay good morning realize that we didn't
film anything outside the last night
about being tipsy oh no we come to
dinner from the dinner a little bit for
those it so quick update it was freezing
on the way home yeah we took the cable
car and then just pop so Mason's up back
to the hotel I said Nina passed out
super early and so today you're just
picking up our car for the hotel Nina
got her Starbucks and we are driving to
San Bruno to go to YouTube's head office
to go meet with my account manager and
see what's up don't get my car going
we're in the YouTube immersion room
after having an awesome lunch
emergency stop I'm in the washer and
above the urinals they have these charts
of fastest-rising emerging and most
watched I'm not so far away from being
emergence under hundred thousand but
hopefully we can get into fastest ride
in rising after we get 100,000
subscribers my goal is to make it unto
the YouTube urinals so while we just got
out of our meeting that was fun my
account manager was super nice and
friendly right took us on a tour I was
not the film anything Nina snuck out
with a salad a bonus salad and some
water and really good he started off
saying you know we see a lot of channels
and there aren't a lot of creators now
who teach us stuff we're seeing new
stuff happening on youtube and and he
loved what we're doing on the channel so
that's cool I like that we're innovating
even though we're a small ish channel in
the YouTube space we're doing stuff
that's on the cutting edge so wait to
get that recognition and feeling pretty
good a one cool thing here is they have
this whole line of electric charging
stations for vehicles where you can
charge up so we're going to drive back
to LA it's one morning they have a
google hangout and then we're going home
right that's it california dreamin
this is me hating LA traffic
so we're talking in the car but how I
haven't had a single Frappuccino since
coming here which is unusual because
usually when I'm on a trip i have
frappuccinos like every day but it's not
the healthiest thing so we're driving
back and I'm talking to get a little
tired i order cappuccino so I can stay
awake am i right home and they gave me
crazy amounts of whipped cream annina
got a water
last night we ended up meeting up with
one of the guys from entrepreneur there
the guy runs our YouTube channel and
looking at potentially doing some work
together so that was fun we met up at
nine o'clock on a Wednesday night then
rushed home started packing I had a
hangout this morning with a Weber but
then crashed because my arrangement with
them which is highly embarrassing not
just for a weber but also for you guys
like you ask me questions you leave
thoughts and comments and I wanted to
answer it so that's not really sucked
and so then we set everything up so
we're doing it again by the time this
video comes out it already happen the
second one but you know that's going to
happen in business right you're going to
have things that go wrong and you just
try to open deliver so we're doing
another hangout on top of the one that I
already hit they got cut off and that
that meant this morning I had to get it
all set ups is like rushing to invite
everybody free dear friend remote it and
then we're rushing to get the drop of
our car and rushing to get to the bus
the Russian to get inside hunkers what
you guys do when you are stressed and
rush
we didn't talk i don't think at all in
the car ride we're just focused on like
let's get that right now
we're here so we finally got here we
managed to bring in the magic bullet
we're worried because it has blades in
it but we're men should bring it in
and we had to pack a bag because of all
of the honest company products you have
to check it so you're gonna have to wait
I hate checking bags but it was worth it
as a lot of good stuff
and that was time to breathe because
we're here and you
and who's the washing and get some food
because the five hour flight and they
don't
and then what else what if you enjoy
most okay
I think the truth been in relaxing
without the rush to hear and your except
for the
the drive and day
I enjoyed on your tunic with you
we don't you do business stuff together
you some of the videos I've on the
grifone the meetings
it's fine did well it was fine business
and pleasure what did they call against
today pleasure for flight home relax and
then go camping so thank you guys for
joining us on our trip last words
believe what's the ground we'll even
have fun all right bye guys